Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connors in autoimmune basics 101. We're going to talk about
basic immunology, basic understanding of autoimmune theory and what we're trying to do to help a
person with autoimmune disease. A lot of things to go over here today. So let's just jump right into
this giving credit where credits do Dr. Tatees Karatsian by mentor and all of this as well. So stages of
autoimmune disease is important to understand this. The three different stages. First is silent
autoimmunity. Don't know that you have autoimmune. You don't have any symptoms of autoimmune disease.
You have no tissue destruction. But if you do a blood test, you show elevated antibodies. So you
can show elevated antibodies to self tissue and yet still not yet have any symptoms or loss of
tissue, tissue damage or anything like that. And we'll explain as you go as you understand the immune
system how that is impossible. Stage two is you're having elevated antibodies, but you're now having
the start of symptoms but no real noticeable loss of tissue or no horrible damage to tissue at
any at this point. So you're starting to get sore hands or tiredness and fatigue, but no real
loss of tissue. In case of a thyroid patient with Hashimoto's, they're starting to get symptoms,
maybe hair loss and some fatigue and some difficulty losing weight, but still their thyroid numbers
are within normal range. So they're still getting adequate supply of thyroid hormone. It's just that
they show positive TPO antibodies and symptoms of low thyroid. Stage three is you have elevated
antibodies. You have the symptoms and now you have measurable tissue destruction stayed with
that same Hashimoto's. Example would be now your T3 is very suppressed, your T4 is suppressed,
TSH is elevated. You might have other thyroid blood test positive as well. And now we have to do
some thyroid replacement or stimulation with nutritional things and things. So we are already here
in stage three. The Hashimoto's, the autoimmunity is damaged. The thyroid gland and now is not
putting out what it should put out. So different stages of autoimmunity can vary. You can
stay in stage three with tissue destruction. You can move from stage one to stage three literally overnight.
You can stay in stage one for decades, never moved to stage two, never moved to stage three.
And the goal in treating a person with autoimmune diseases is not to have them and take this
person on in stage three and think that they're not going to have autoimmune disease. The goal in
treated autoimmune disease is to get them into a more silent state, is to get them into a state where
they may still already have tissue destruction. Yes, but you're called me down the immune response.
You're not getting continued tissue destruction and they're you're called me down their symptoms.
So you're really moving them backwards in a way and trying to keep them in a backwards. You're
basically trying to manage this to try to keep it in an autoimmune reactivity state or in a more
silent state and teaching the patient how to understand this and how to manage it himself,
manage it. That's really the goal in treating autoimmune disease. It's not in making autoimmune disease
go away. So how do you know you have an autoimmune disease? Well, you really test for antibodies,
but there are some clues. So there's some clinical red flags for a practitioner. These are red flags
for you as a patient as well. I've tried everything and nothing is cured by complaints.
And various treatments have helped the times and then it made it worse. That's a real common thing.
Let's say if they have live disease, I was on you know cats clawed and seemed to help for a
period of time. Then it just made it worse. That's a good chance you're in an autoimmune phase.
If you're using TH1 immune stimulants and it's making it worse, that's a good chance you're in auto
immune phase. If you have multiple adverse reactions to foods or chemicals, I can't even go into a
new building. The smell of a new building just makes me sick. You're overly sensitive to mold.
I have tons of food sensitivities. That's a good sign you have self-hantabodies.
You have a number of diagnoses. You've been to 20 different doctors.
That's a really that's your one of your best indicators. You have an autoimmune disease that has
not been diagnosed or has not been adequately managed. So when we see a person that's been everywhere,
nobody can figure about it's most likely an autoimmune disease. They have a large
file of labs, countless models of supplements. They have covered full of supplements that they've
tried because they read something on social media that this is the cure for this symptom. They
try that. It just doesn't help. Nothing seems to help them. Or they're diagnosed already.
They already know they have a disease but nobody's ever told them their hypothyroid is actually
Hashimoto's. Or that their diabetes, they thought it was type 2 diabetes. It could actually be an adult
onset type 1 diabetes. You could have antibodies to your island cells in your pancreas and that's
really the cause of the diabetes. Inflammatory bowel disease but it actually could be
antibody related. So all these diseases can have an autoimmune component to it and people have never
been diagnosed with this. So those are red flags you're looking for. And what you're trying to do
from a clinical standpoint with is number one help identify an undiagnosed autoimmune patient.
I help them identify the different stages. Remember stage one is silent stage two autoimmune
reactivity in stage three full blown autoimmune disease where you have tissue destruction.
And then the biggest thing that we're going to be working through with this course is learning how to
identify lifestyle triggers. Because this autoimmune disease is there. You're going to have antibodies
that will be there most likely for the rest of your life. You have to know how to manage it. You need
to learn how to manage the triggers. Is it lack of sleep? Is it exercised too much? Is it that I have
emotional issues? Are there food triggers? You're identifying dietary triggers. So different proteins
in different foods. You can develop antibodies too. And that will once you eat that and you
stimulated immune reaction because of that antibody that you have for gluten. Let's say that it
fires up the rest of your whole autoimmune cascade. So you have antibodies to gluten. You eat that.
It fires an immune reaction. You also have antibodies to your thyroid and Hashimoto's. It's going to
fire an immune reaction there. You're going to kill that which you have antibodies against first.
You're going to damage self tissue if you have self tissue antibodies. So understanding dietary
triggers is super important. I can't tell you how many line patients that I've talked to that are
in stage three phase three line with autoimmune line and they don't know it. And they actually have
antibodies to neural tissue. And because they don't know it, they don't think that their food
antigens really cause any problems. They're not going to change their diet. Well, every time they
eat something, maybe they don't, they eat, let's use gluten as an example, maybe they eat gluten.
It doesn't cause any stomach ache, but it causes foggy thinking and they can't put their finger on it
because they eat gluten every day. And they say, well, I have foggy thinking all the time. I can't
even think straight. I can't get out of bed. I feel achy. I have all this inflammation. It's not
gluten. I tried to stay away from it one time and it didn't help. Well, you have to find all the
identified, all these dietary protein triggers, like not just be gluten. Maybe it's gluten and
nightchains. It's gluten and lectins. Maybe it's it's dairy and in scallops, you have to test for
these things because if you don't get rid of them, you are firing literally a burning fire in your
gut. Whether you feel it or not, that's going to fire this immune response elsewhere.
You will kill that what you have antibodies against first. So you'll start destroying self-tissue
when you have a self-tissue antibodies. So you have to identify these triggers. So just ignore it.
If a patient says that, well, I don't have gut issues. I know I don't. So I know I don't have food
allergies. If they have autoimmune issues, they have food sensitivities. I'll guarantee it. They
have antibodies to foods. You have to test for that and find that. And then identify chemical triggers.
It can be pollutants. It can be chemical that they're using in their in their hair products. It can
be chemicals that you're using in your in your lotions. It can be, you know, clean products in your
house. It can be something your husband is spraying on the lawn. These are all triggers that
fire an immune response. It can have a delayed response. So it can be days or even weeks later after
exposure. And now you can't get off the couch. So you have to look and dig. You have to be an investigator.
You have to put out your Sherlock Holmes hat if you have an autoimmune disease.
Identify other antigen active antigen triggers. Those are pathogens. Are you exposed to a virus or
a bacteria or parasites or mold? You know, you can't get a person better if they're in a mold house.
And they have an autoimmune disease. You know, that mold exposure on a constant basis is
firing this immune response. And you will, you will damage what you have antibodies again. So you're
going to fire that self autoimmune self antibody response. And you're going to have inflammation in
your body. You have to identify a breakdown of your immune barriers. So your immune barriers,
your barriers in your body, your gut barrier, your lung barrier, your nasal phasal,
pharynx barrier, your blood brain barrier, your skin barrier. These are barriers that keep
pathogens out of your body, that keep bacteria out of your body, that keep bad chemicals,
that chemicals that you shouldn't be absorbing through your lung barrier, your gut barrier,
things that shouldn't be crossing your blood brain barrier. You need to work on supporting those
barriers and healing those barriers. And then identifying mechanisms to prove immune tolerance. We're
going to talk about that a little bit more in this presentation, but immune tolerance is very
important. Stimulating your T-reg cells, keeping a balanced T-reg system. So they should not
overbalance TH1 or overbalance TH2 that identify strategies to recover from flare ups. This is
all has to do with lifestyle and diet and the proper nutrition, proper exercise, proper lifestyle.
So you can see this isn't easy. Dealing with autoimmune issues isn't easy. If you go to a practitioner
that says they have the simple solution to autoimmunity, you should turn and run as fast as you can,
because there is no simple solution to autoimmunity. You have to look at a lot of different things
when you're dealing with this. There's multiple immune factors in autoimmunity. You can have
depressed white blood cell production, leading to immune dysregulation. You can have an active infection,
meaning that you have a current viral load, a current bacterial load, mold load,
spirochete with Lyme disease, an active pathogen that's up regulating the immune system. You can have
barrier permeability that we talked about, overactive phagocytes, cells, bodocytes, neutrophils,
eocinophils, vasophils, bacrophages, dendritic cells, coupe for cells, and microglia in the brain.
Huge problem is microglial damage. I have a video on microglial damage. Make sure you watch that as well.
Loss of your complement protein system, your complement protein system is literally your immune
landmines throughout the body, city there to kill pathogens, but you could have a loss of balance in
that, and you could have an up-regulation of that, or a down-regulation of that. You could have an
overactive complement protein system, or an underactive complement protein system. An abnormal T-cell
differentiation, your overbalance TH-1, your overbalance TH-2. What we're seeing more and more is
overbalance TH-17, this hyper-inflammation response. You need to balance it with your T-reg cells,
your TH-3 cells, to help stimulate regulation and help stimulate support to balance out your
T-cell differentiation. Different dysfunction throughout your immune system, chemical-induced
immune dysfunction, abnormal microbiome. We'll talk about that a little bit, and the psycho-neural
immune promotion of an immune dysregulation. You see this very common with Lyme disease,
much more so than with some of the other autoimmune issues. Brain injury, traumatic brain injury itself
can cause an autoimmune disease and cause damaged microglial cells and prime microglial cells.
It gets very complicated, as you can see. We're not just talking about the individual immune cells
when we're dealing with an autoimmune situation. It isn't your immune cells going to
rise. It's something that's happened to your immune cells exposure to different things that your
immune system is reacting in a way that is really actually normal for that thing, but you were never
supposed to be exposed to that thing. Let's first talk about some permeability of the barriers
in autoimmune disease. You have your lung and your nasal pharynx and your epithelial barrier
of your lung, but when it's air pollution, you've got cigarette smoke, you've got infections that
can enter your body that way, certainly chemicals affects your glutathione production,
the oxidation and redux of your glutathione support system there. Eventually, if there's constant
irritation, let's let's say in the use of constant cigarette smoke, you're going to have breakdown
of your glutathione antioxidant system and that's going to damage cells. You're going to have
opened up cells. Instead of having those tight junctions of the cells, you're going to have separation
damage of that barrier and the things are going to get across the barrier that never should have gotten
across the barrier. So understand a barrier is like a fence. The barrier in your lungs and your nasal
pharynx is not much different than your intestinal barrier and it functions the same though it's
totally different cells with your blood brain barrier. So the epithelial barrier and your lung and
your intestines are very similar and those can separate and break and because of cell damage
and things get across that never should have gotten across. If you watch the video yet about foods and
why you test foods, I explain that a little bit more deeper that proteins as they break down into
peptides and then ultimately down into single amino acids that are supposed to grow across the intestinal
barrier. When you have a damage intestinal barrier, things get across that never should have gotten
across the gaps between the cells are much larger than if you had a healthy barrier there and that's
where we start to develop antibodies because things get across that never should have gotten across
our immune system looks at them and actually functions normally in trying to kill that thing but if that
thing is a chemical or that thing is a peptide of a food or some pollution or some you know
toxin of some sort it's not going to die so your immune system is trying to kill this thing makes
antibodies against this thing. Now you have circulated antibodies against food peptides.
Now every time you eat that food you're going to fire an immune response. So damaged barriers is
super super common. I mean this is just you don't even need to do a you know a gut barrier test
to know if you have a gut barrier damage. If you have an autoimmune issue, if you have issues
health issues that you're unable to resolve and is making your life miserable, you have to just assume
that you have damage to these barrier systems and if you have upper motor neuron issues meaning
you know head issues, brain issues, certainly even symptoms of the rest of your body can be coming
from your brain, your pyridolome can cause. If you have inflammation of the pyridolome of the brain,
it could cause a sensational issue anywhere else in the body. I mean I could have the sensory
of knee pain, but it's actually caused from my pyridolome in the area of where my knee, the
aphyrid connection of my knee connects to the brain. So I can think my knee is killing me because my
knee is actually really killing me, but it's actually caused for inflammation of the pyridolome
at that area of the knee in the pyridolome in the brain. So a lot of upper motor neuron issues,
a lot of sensory symptoms that we have, a lot of motor issues that we have are really from
inflammation in the brain and it's a damaged blood-brain area, blood-brain barrier and that blood
brain barrier is made up from astrocytes in your brain and those it's very difficult to heal. So
you have to be knowledge of that, you have to be even more specific and concerned with what
you're exposed to. So it does have to do, boils down to a lot of lifestyle changes, but understanding
the barriers and trying to heal the barriers and protect your body, knowing you have damaged barriers
is one of the key to managing autoimmune disease. Here's just a picture of the barrier in the
lungs, the barrier in the center is the barrier in the gut and the blood-brain barrier on the right
and how things can get across those barriers that never should have got across those barriers.
Well, there's damage to that barrier and then our body makes antibodies to those things in an attempt
to kill them, but if they're not things that can kill that it can die because they'll be in organisms
now you've got circulated antibodies and you've got this immune reaction to these things in an attempt
to kill it and if you already have self antibodies, any immune reaction for any reason is going to
increase the likelihood that there's going to be more damage to self tissue and this is what
the sense people to the couch because they can't cope with life and it really has to do with the
barrier system to somebody who that's that's damaged and and stimulates an autoimmune reaction
and makes them worse. So this is where you got these cyclical changes with autoimmune disease,
they might feel better prepared at time and I don't know what I did. I just didn't. It wasn't anything
that I did. I just you know and then they crash. You got to work on all these things at the same time.
You got to work on healing these barriers. So understand you have innate immunity and adaptive
immunity. There's a few different ways to classify this. We're going to go through a couple different
classifications. Your innate immunity is really how you deal with something like an acute infection,
your natural killer cells, your mass cells are going to really fire first and you cause a reaction
to stimulate a bunch of cytokine production, histamine is going to be brought into the area to
polion natural killer cells. Natural killer cells are there to kill. They're your number one
killers of a bacterial infection or a viral infection is your natural killer cell response.
You got your wandering dendritic cells and your macrophages. Over time they'll wander into the area
into that tissue site of infection and they will help through phagocytosis kill bacteria or pathogen
also. Then they also the dendritic cell functions as an antigen presented cell to basically
presented the B cell. Here is this antigen that we're trying to kill that we're having difficulty kill
either the B cells make antibodies stimulate a T cell response so that you have other killer cells
in the area through communication with these chemicals called cytokines and chemokines and then your
antibodies that are made by the B cells are then attached to the antigen so your natural killer cells
and your lymphocytic T cells can identify them and kill them so that's how your immune system works.
Another kind of picture of this in the center of the screen is an antigen so think of an antigen
is that what your body that's what your immune system is trying to kill so normally an antigen
should only be a pathogen so normally an antigen should only be a pathogen meeting a living
organism, a virus, a bacteria, something like that that your immune system can kill so remember
you have two types of systems that get rid of things in your body you have your detoxification pathways
in which you're supposed to get rid of chemicals and then you have your immune system pathways in which
you kill bad guys so the immune system isn't supposed to fire against non-living things but
non-living things are supposed to be entering into your body but when you have a damaged barrier
remember you end up getting peptides of foods that never should have made its way into the bloodstream
is now under the bloodstream and our immune system is firing a reaction against this
as if it is an antigen because technically it is an antigen what our immune system fires
a reaction against it so anything that your immune system is attempting to kill is an antigen
again antigen should only be pathogens in a perfect world but when antigens are heavy metal let's
say that antigen is mercury right there and you're going to fire an NK cell natural killer cell
response to it is it going to kill mercury no so what happens your T helper cells are trying to
stimulate and bigger NK cell in a cytotoxic C cells T cell response that's a little bit farther
down on that red line the T helper cells are up regulating the natural killer cells are up
regulating the cytotoxic T cells so that they can fire a more prominent attack against this bad guy
but if this bad guy is an unliving thing let's say mercury then it can't kill it so you're you can't
kill this thing and then your T suppressor cells over on the left are trying to calm down the T helper
cells your T regulator cells are trying to regulate this whole process and orchestrate this whole process
the antigen can be grabbed onto by an antigen presented cell that APC that presented to a B cell
in order to make antibodies against it and this is how a cascade can take place if this mercury settles
inside the cell or attaches to a receptors on the outside of a cell your B cells can actually make
antigens can make can make antibodies against self tissue this is what can predispose this is what
can cause an autoimmune disease in the first place at that antigen is lying burgodorphia
beryllia and your immune system is unable to kill it in that antigen that burgodorphic goes inside
the cell or attaches to the receptor of a cell membrane trying to hide and protect itself your B
cells can make antibodies against the cell tissue of the cells that this is attaching to this receptor
that it's attaching to or the cells that it's hiding in this is how an autoimmune disease begins
so again the definition of an autoimmune disease is that you have antibodies against your own
cells that a good thing well how does that happen that means our immune system is gone to rye and
it's a bad immune system no it's actually your immune system is doing everything it's possibly can do
it's that that thing is either tricky your immune system to make antibodies against its own tissue
the case of on in case of autoimmune disease cause from a pathogen or it's an autoimmune disease
cause because of toxicity that your immune system is making antibodies against self tissue in the hopes
to basically kill that tissue and thereby get rid of that pathogen get rid of that ant to get rid of
that antigen whatever it is so kind of complicated right I have to go through that several times but
this is how your immune system kills things it's a good thing it's not a bad immune system it's
trying to kill things problem is if it's trying to kill things that aren't killable or aren't easily
killable that's where we have a problem so here's another picture better graphic maybe on this side
the th1 this picture the th1 side is on the right the th2 side is on the left doesn't make any
difference in that th3 the conductor down in the center he's the t reg cell he's trying to balance
this whole thing so you can see if I have a full autoimmune disease the more support I could give
to my t reg system my th3 system to balance this all out it's going to help calm down my symptoms
so this we could talk about this slide for about an hour but I won't go into any more depth of that
if we look at a white blood cell panel this is typically what you're going to see this is a cvc
with differential so you got white blood cells that's your total white blood cells on the top
that you got red blood cells he will go ahead and he will create let's go down to the white blood cell
separation he got neutrophils monocytes baza fills and then the absolute neutrophils monocytes he
instead of fills baza fills these are your phagocytic cells this is your innate this is your immediate
response cell that's trying to kill a pathogen and then you have your lymphocytes your adaptive
immune system your total b cells your t cells and then your natural killer cells that are killing off
your pathogens that you're exposed to then we have the function of other chemicals in our body
the edF capa beta that's nuclear factor capa beta is a hyper immune response that is understand
anything in your body is not bad or good it's all about balance all right so edF capa beta has a
function in your body to stimulate in immune response the problem is is you could get on what's
called an edF capa beta amplifying loop so it's imbalance that makes something bad so go up to the
top left of this picture you got inflammatory cytokines inflammatory pollutants causing
environmental pollutants causing inflammatory cytokines dietary peptides meaning you have a
sensitivity to a food you have antibodies to a food you have any antigen of any sort
it's going to activate your edF capa beta system it's to activate an immune response that's
what edF capa beta is for it's to activate an immune response is to stimulate your TH1
to stimulate your TH17 those are all good things it's when it's out of balance that is the problem
so if I have an autoimmune disease and I'm constantly exposed to food peptides that I already have
antibodies against meeting simplify this if I have an autoimmune disease and I don't know if I have
a gluten sensitivity but I do let's say I have antibodies to some gluten peptides and I'm continuing to
eat gluten what that's going to do it's going to be constantly activated activated edF capa beta
just loopy that loopy that every time I'm eating that thing it's going to just stimulate either
TH1 or TH2 dominance depending on the person it's going to be stimulating by TH17 system which is
going to be hyper inflammatory it's going to be activated systemic inflammation it's supposed to say
say stomach on the bottom it's going to be activated a systemic inflammatory response it's going to be
activating intestinal tight junction breakdown it's going to be damaging not just intestinal but
lung and other barrier breakdown it's going to be it's going to continue to stimulate this
constant inflammation it's going to continue to break down by barrier systems and then that's going
to interred stimulate autoimmune activity so if I already have antibodies to my thyroid and I am
you know exposed to environmental foods or exposed to foods that I already have antibodies against
or exposed to some environmental antigen or even exposed to viruses and bacteria it's going to make
my autoimmune situation worse it's going to stimulate destruction in this example of my thyroid
gland even more so can't figure out why I'm even more tired I'm still taking I'm going to check
my thyroid dosage my dosage might be off but then let's you go to the doctor and get your blood
tested your and your T3 and your T4 your TSH are still with a normal limits and I don't know what's
wrong you know it's because whatever you did that day stimulated this reaction stimulated
over abundance of inflammation that stimulated autoimmune activation it's complicated doesn't it
this is depressing it gets very complicated but you have to know these things as a patient you have
to know the things that are stimulating your immune system and things that could block it you
notice in the center of the screen resveratrol a curcumin have been shown in studies over and over
to help block the NF capabeta loop we could also add green t extract most of your flavonoids to that
so there's things that you can do you know well I'm just going to take these supplements so that's
going to be my solution it doesn't work that way you have to deal with all these stimulated factors
to calm this whole thing down that has to do with this whole concept of self tolerance you have a
loss of self tolerance the more things that you're exposed to that is that is disrupting your
immune system different toxins and pollutants it's never just one thing some people think oh I just
have this problem it's because of my Lyme disease it just it just is not it's never one thing it's
a cascade of things the more the more aspects that you can deal with as a patient it's learned to
self manage the better you're going to be because it's it's a combination of a multiple things
that cause this immune dysregulation and just complete loss of self tolerance and this is when people
crash so then you end up with the production of self tissue antibodies and you know in the if you
have the presence of look at the left of the screen where you have lower tissue amount of NF
capabata a higher amount of TH3 remember that's your T-reg cells and a lower amount of TH17 which is
going to be hyper stimulation which if it was higher it'd be hyper stimulation of inflammation so
you have lower amount of inflammation greater amount of T-reg cells a lower amount of NF capabata
inflammation you're going to stay more in a silent immunity silent auto immunity but the greater
about this inflammation you have the less regulation you have of your immune response you're going to
end up with more damage so this is a good slide to memorize because this is going to be good to help
balance things and then there's the whole concept of understanding how your microbiota helps balance
this and stay in place there's a number of studies that are out that show a healthy microbiota that's
the healthy flora in your gut in your lungs you have microbiota throughout all your body even on your
skin surface the healthier you can keep that through eating good food that's the number one way you
increase the healthier microbiota it's not just taking it's not taking probiotics it's eating good
balanced diet you're going to that is going to protect your barrier that's going to protect against
pathogens that's going to decrease inflammation overall inflammation and I get it you think well
I'm just going to start taking a probiotic to get a healthy microbiota what you have to do honestly
you have to start by what's damaging my microbiota and what is your biggest thing that damages your
microbiota inflammation well where do I get by the most inflammation that I got from food from
your food not just poor food choices but eating foods that might be actually good foods that you
have developed antibodies against so if I have antibodies against KC dairy and I continue to eat dairy
and I don't have any symptoms with it you're causing inflammation of the gut unhealthy microbiota
it increase inflammation systemically and it increase um up regulation of an autoimmune response
and damage to self tissue I don't care if you got gut stomach it got problems so so important to
keep your microbiota healthy and then the psycho neural immune response is so essential we talked a
little bit about the microglial damage that could take place with autoimmune disease really have to go
back and watch my video on neuro inflammation and microglial damage and how microglial cells can be
compromised and then just become sitting there and spewing out inflammatory cytokines but there's
other cascades that take place that cause this without having the full blown you know antibodies to
neural tissue your immune system response in your gut or in any barrier area is going to stimulate
cytokines that are going to directly affect the immune system in the brain and directly upregulate
microglial activity in the brain stimulation of the vagal nerve through irritation to the vagal
nerve and damage to the vagal nerve in the gut is going to cause direct damage to the brain as well
if there's damage to the gut in inflammation the gut that's going to cause it in balance and
neurotransmitters that affects the brain direct brain affect with the amygdala and through the HPA
the access direct is going to affect hormone function is going to affect your whole body and it's
certainly going to affect the neurons themselves so there is just such a cascade of problems that happens
when we talk about autoimmune issues that it's just not a simple thing to deal with you have to look
at as many different factors as possible that if you're going to really see success in dealing with
autoimmune disease so we could go through these again we talked about this slide already these are
things that are taking place some people could have you know depressed white blood cells and and the
loss of complement system and chemical binding tissue protein some people can that is their major
issue some people's major issue is their is their microglial system and their brain and the inflammation
of the brain that's causing it in balance in the HPA access and causing it in balance in hormone
production and fatigue is their main thing some people are going to have an abnormal T cell differentiation
and they're just hyper TH1 and they and that is their main thing that they're dealing with and just
call me that out and stimulated T regs is going to be the biggest thing that's going to help balance
them the idea is that every single person is different with autoimmune disease they're going to have a
very personalized combination of things that are causing dysfunctional patterns in their immune system
you as the patient have to educate yourself and you as the patient the responsibility ultimately
falls on you to see where your triggers are and find your triggers I would rather have you spend your
money in testing and in figuring this stuff out so that you can better manage your lifestyle but ultimately
the responsibility does fall on you as the patient to to then make the lifestyle choices that are
going to help you and these are I'm not trying to to to make light of these it's difficult it's hard
to stay out of gluten free dairy free diet it is really hard to stay out of paleo audio autoimmune
diet it's really hard to stay away from these foods that everybody else seems to eat with no problems
what I eat in my get brain fog and all sorts of problems of anger and whatever it is so it's very
difficult but the more ways that you can see how you can that you can deal with this cascade of
problems that you're that you're suffering from um though it's very complex the more ways that you
can see okay if I need to balance this and need to balance this is where you can find what's going
to be a perfect balance for you to try to move you from stage three full blown tissue destruction to
hey now I can live my life a little bit and and my symptoms have calmed down so that's what we're
trying to do and educate you with all of this I know we went through a lot of information and just
you know 40 minutes here you might have to listen to this a couple times but um know that we'll
be praying for you know that we're going to be constantly adding educational information so that you
can better self-direct your care thanks bye bye